- Good morning Believe Nation.
My name is Lily Ma and my
one word is extraordinary.
I believe that every single human being
is capable of extraordinary things.
So, to help you on your journey,
today's message is create your own luck.
Over to you, Donald Trump.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
What would be one word of advice
you would have for an
upcoming businessman,
for a future businessman?
- Uhm.
- Or a woman.
- Knowledge. Knowledge.
But if it's one word.
One word's very hard for that,
but the word is knowledge.
But you get knowledge through experience.
One of the things people
talk about is luck,
and I do believe that people are lucky
and some people are luckier than others.
I do believe that.
But there's also an expression,
the harder you work, the luckier you get.
And I can tell you 10
instances where I didn't quit.
One, it was 1990, the
world was coming down,
the debt markets were down,
everybody all of my friends and enemies
were going bankrupt, I never did.
The times were, actually just terrible.
And even today, you look at times
and you see what happens
and you have to learn.
But, the word luck is very interesting,
but if I didn't work really hard,
I'd probably would not,
almost definitely would not
be here today and unless you had me up
as a man who at one point was successful,
but let's see what a loser looks like.
So you have to work
hard because it is true.
You can develop luck through hard work.
- So I think luck plays a
part in people's success,
but a really small part.
It becomes a problem if
that's all you focus on.
It becomes a problem when
you use it as an excuse
not to go out there and do
something with your life.
It becomes an even bigger
problem if you're always waiting
for luck to come your way.
So for example, I'm just
starting out as a speaker.
I'm in my early stages
of my speaking career.
I look at Evan.
He just went to Paris
and he spoke in front of
thousands of people,
ate at a fancy restaurant,
sat at first-class airlines,
went to a beautiful hotel,
and he was given this opportunity
and he is so lucky.
Right?
That is not the mindset
that I need to have.
That kind of mindset will
completely destroy my future
and will not help me grow.
The reason why Evan had that opportunity
is through years and years of
dedicated hard work over time.
I work with that man.
I know how consistent he is.
I know how determined he is.
And I know how dedicated
he is to his mission.
And the reason why I don't have
that luck or that opportunity,
is because I don't deserve it yet.
And it's no way for me to
knock myself down at all.
Instead, it raises me even higher
because I am not waiting
for some elusive fairy
to come around and
sprinkle dust over my head
that is called luck for this to happen.
It is within my control.
I have the responsibility
and accountability
to make that happen for myself.
I need to work harder.
I need to work harder
consistently over time,
keep working, keep working,
be dedicated to my mission,
keep working, gain
knowledge through research,
and soon enough that
opportunity will come my way.
So next time you look at someone
that you think has a lot
of luck in their life,
change your mindset around and find ways
to create your own luck.
So the question of the day is,
what is that one
opportunity you really want
in your life that hasn't
happened for you yet?
And hopefully when you write it down,
it's going to give you the fuel, the fire
to go and make your own luck.
So leave in the comments below
and I'll join in on the discussion.
So I also have a quick
shout out for Evan Lieanto,
thank you so much for picking up a copy of
Evan's book, Your One Word.
Your support means a lot to us
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you so much for watching.
I believe in you and I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I think that's one
of the strongest things
you can cultivate as an entrepreneur
is to not rely on luck,
but cultivating an ability to recognize
fortunate situations
when they're occurring.
Odeo was a very fortunate situation.
Could've taken that idea,
not told it to Ev, not told
it to Biz, not told it to Noah
and all my other coworkers at Odeo
and tried to start my own
company with that idea.
But the fortunate situation was that
I was working with some
really amazing people
and we had a great team.
And so of course it makes
sense to start there.
The fortunate situation for Square,
was that in 2008, the end of 2008,
the entire market was crashing down.
All of these abstractions we built upon,
abstraction upon
abstraction upon abstraction
in the financial world which
no single human understood,
were now falling apart and suddenly
we're getting back to
basics, back to fundamentals,
management teams were
being asked to leave,
banks were failing, people
were clarifying around
we need to start getting innovative,
we need to stop treating
our customers so poorly,
we need to stop encouraging
bad behavior that reap fees.
Like, we really need to turn
this whole thing around.
And anytime there's a
recession or a depression,
that's a great time to
innovate, start a company,
start a project, do anything.
We recognize that time
and at the same time, my co-founder Jim,
he contacted me, I've known
him since I was 15 years old,
he was my boss when I was 15 years old.
And, he's like, Jack
I want to talk to you.
I want to build an electronic car company.
That's interesting and
he was thinking about it
because the car industry
was failing as well.
He's like, why don't we just
give these car companies
to well-seasoned entrepreneurs.
Why don't we Ford to Steve Jobs.
- That would be amazing.
- Yeah, it would be amazing.
And GM to Ellison or whatnot
and also I want to start
an electronic car company
and I'm like, that's ambitious.
But in that moment we decided
not to start an electronic car company,
but we wanted to do something together.
And we kept having these
weekly conversations
about what that thing was.
And I was researching a lot
with finance and healthcare
because I was looking at doing
something in those spaces.
And Jim called me one day in one of those
scheduled meetings and he said,
I just lost a glass sale.
He's an artist; he sells glass.
And I lost the sale because I
couldn't accept a credit card.
And here he was talking on his iPhone,
this general purpose computer
and I was talking on my iPhone.
- A one gigahertz computer
sitting in the palm of your hand
but no way to accept credit cards.
- He couldn't accept $2,000 from someone
who wanted to pay him, why is that?
So we decided that we wanted
to answer that question.
And we did a bunch of research,
I started writing some server code
and we hired a guy to
write some iPhone code
and Jim built some hardware
and in a month we had a little,
well, it was actually quite a big device
that plugged into the
audio jack of your iPhone
and could swipe a card, take a payment,
it would go through the merchant process
and then generate a
receipt with a map on it.
I went around and showed
it to a bunch of investors.
They were all amazed
that it could even work.
So we decided to really focus
on it and make it a company.
It really just comes down to recognizing
that fortunate situation and recognizing
the people around you that could help
and just honing it.
- You were bold, you
kind of talked him up,
you ended up selling his
house but you approached him
and you said, are you ready
to sell one of your houses?
You already knew that he owned two houses,
you knew where they were,
so isn't that also a big part of this.
You have to really do the hard work?
- Yeah and really preparing
yourself to be lucky.
Putting yourself in situations
where you can get lucky.
Where it's not so much
luck, it's preparation.
I tell a story about how I'm standing
inside a line at Starbucks,
and I'm not at that Starbucks
because I like coffee,
I'm at that Starbucks because that's
where all the wealthy people
and all the celebrities
in Beverly Hills go every morning.
I meet a guy in line in front of me,
I end up showing him a
house later that afternoon
and he buys a 12 million dollar house.
Some people will say that's luck.
For me, it's all about
being at the right place
and there was a reason why I'm there
because I'm an expert in my community
and I put myself in that situation.